il a tout chanter ria les lacs du
connemara ya la maladie d'amour et
michel sardou c'est un très grand
artiste mais c'est aussi un bon client
sera plateaux de télé en radio il ya
beaucoup d'imagés qui nous ont marqués
on voulait vous en montrer quelques
jeunesse qui me rappelait michel sardou
a interprété le tube je vole de cas
repris ensuite luan regarder mes chers
parents
[Applaudissements]
vous n'aurez plus d'enfants ce soir je
ne m'en suis pas je vaux
comprenez bien je veux
sans fumée 101
je vous
cette fin elle a été reprise par luan
elle avait dit une fois qu'elle n'avait
pas le droit de la santé et sur europe 1
michel sardou avait réagi regarder enfin
qu'on demande à lou ann de chanter je
vole elle dit non non j'ai pas le droit
est ce que c'est vous michel sardou qui
lui interdisait de chanter je veux le
titre elle dit des conneries en fait
c'est sa promotion
le film à 7 millions et demi d'entrées
on ferme sa gueule en est content du
merci mon dieu parce que c'est quand
même pas c'est pas jurassique or c'est
un petit fils gentille sympathique et
dis ça mais en fait elle n'est pas très
maligne dasquié la chantier une fondue
ou peut-être cette chanson avec lohan
n'aurait bien maintenant dans ce réseau
seront prêts oui disent qu'ils pensent
quoi il est caché les fronts c'est
génial alors dans sa carrière michel
sardou a chanté avec les plus grands
comme avec johnny hallyday l'âme
interpréter longvic regardez
[Musique]
il reste un jeu très copain michel
sardou et chauny et ensuite ils se sont
fait on l'a on lire dans un dock
diffusée sur w9
il avait expliqué que leur amitié avait
pris fin à cause d'une remarque de
michel sardou sur les enfants de johnny
regarde mais il va suffire d'une petite
phrase pour que cette amitié de 30 ans
vole en éclats nous sommes en 2008 et
johnny hallyday vient de vivre l'un de
ses plus grands bonheurs l'adoption au
vietnam de sa fille jade
des témoins affirment alors que michel
sardou aurait fait une très vilaine
blague sur jade lors d'un concert johnny
est venu avec sa viet congs ah oui oui
la belle ce qui est toujours un lieu
dans ce genre de truc c'est machin dit
que milieu la 10ème jour en milieu non
ça a été filmé il n'a pas démenti et
stephen un cancer en 2008 dont gray
avait donc oui je t'ai vu ce
documentaire
voilà où les lions ont connu pour sa
franchise à michel sardou sur le plateau
d'on n'est pas couché doivent expliquer
qu'il n'aimait pas faire des autographes
regardez il avait passé signé s'il y
essayer des trucs sur des bouts de
papier sur les trucs bon ça ça ça me
fait toujours en musique et ça me gêne
un peu en appel d'une belle siens à
liège enfin lui ai dit qu'ils signent le
retour du gip kaunas et
kefu avec sardou suis persuadé que ça va
cartonner ce soir exactement
regardez d'ailleurs ce soir ah oui je
vais regarder moi c'est très attendu
mais ce qui est très étonnant c'est que
il a toujours divisé sarthois mais il
n'a jamais fait l'unanimité
et là maintenant voilà tout le monde est
derrière lui sans doute parce que c'est
la dernière fois
mais tout le monde adore aujourd'hui
c'est que la belle je peux vous dire
qu'à lyon le conservions donc le même
qu'à la scène musicale il y avait
absolument toutes les tranches d'âge
dans la salle nous tout moi ça m'a vu du
très coté quoi ces dessous c'est à 110 à
120 75 de plus il a vendu 90 millions
d'albums non tant les deux mois que
johnny et la salle une arme teulier new
delhi alors moi michel sardou je le
connais un petit peu parce que et on
habitait dans le même immeuble pendant
des années vous lit il habitait au
dessus de mon chez moi et il était très
sympa je le voyais dans l'ascenseur à
chaque fois on se parlait très
cordialement dalle au rez de chaussée
tous les deux ont rigolé et sa femme et
délicieux dans mais serena est hélas
toujours été très sympa michel sardou et
alors c'est vrai qu'il est connu pour sa
franchise en souvient alors que lors
d'une émission en son honneur qui était
diffusée sur france 2 l'année dernière
il y avait une séquence assez insolite
entre lui et stéphane bern si au sujet
des réseaux sociaux ou regarder si l'ue
de réagir sur les réseaux sociaux avec
le hashtag sardines à quel point je tape
ces revues ça n'existe pas le hashtag
jalousie commencer quoi hkd de lire quoi
sérieuse en fait c'est diesel moi je
suis pas un mec à acheter
je suis du mal à trouver le bouton pomme
pour faire
truc tu vois non mais je comprends en
même temps maintenant on communique en
140 signes
on n'a pas le droit +1 sur twitter mais
je n'ai jamais été sur twitter mais je
ne vois que des défis qui montrent leur
cul sur twitter ah oui bah oui vraiment
classe 48,3 la transition comme kelly
vous avez 28 ans est ce que michel
sardou ça vous parle ou pas du tout mais
pas du tout non ça trésor que regarder
ça ce soir merci vous savez que ça bien
sûr franchement à quoi ça te dit rien du
tout mais ça me dit vous avez une
chanson de michel sardou
oui c'est quoi nan nan nan non merci
allez salut c'est ça alors quoi oui non
je dis que michel sardou ya à la fois
les chansons etc
et puis c'est une belle voix qui s'en va
puisque ces derniers concerts et bien
son parcours maja bien des parcours
la parcours d'un homme qui a eu ses
parents comédiens qui s'est fait tout
seul qui a abandonné ses études et qui
très vite s'est lancée dans la chanson
par michel fugain et je trouve que c'est
une force très forte d'arriver à se
faire un nom
finalement tout seul avec un parcours
parfois difficile alors une hormis ces
autres coups de gueule michel sardou
s'en était pris à nicolas canteloup
apparemment il n'était pas fan de ses
imitations garder michel bon pas trop
dur le réveil ce matin michel bagoul
bien sûr j'ai dit au matin jules matin
vos cheveux
et vous habiller un joli genève un café
ça m'emmerde les matins michel sardou un
petit bout pour des collègues et ses
mimiques macmillan en fait il parle en
fait comme lui c'est un très bon
cavalier
je félicite pour sa méprise imitation
habille toi mon pote c'est pas du tout
mon roi tu es toi tais toi c'est pas du
tout ma boîte
[Applaudissements]
idem bien nicolas petit va regarder
franchement le conserver ou géraldine
pensez-vous boxing est mort à l'époque
je m'étais le cd avec omar sy 92
ouais merci quelques ombres douces avec
happy je prie aime ça mais je l'écoutais
away s'explique beaucoup de choses ouais
ouais on voulait également pour montrer
cette image en 1918 michel sardou et
étend les émissions des carpentier
rejeter les options de divertissement
mais voilà ils pouvaient 87 il était en
irlande avec moi dans le connemara
pendant une semaine mais quelques uns je
peux vous dire c'est la dette mais
correct de toute l'équipe je sais les
gens là dans la foi dans son interview
la dhimma plus à l'année ses 85 ans
regardez le décor s'était effondré à
j'adore
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sardou est ce que brad et tout seul ce
but est venu dans cette même piste il
avait fait il avait chanté en duo avec
moctar c'était un truc un très grand
moment pour la chanson française garder
la main dans le coeur
de 7 à 77 ans elle chante
le champ arrière
qui est ce on lit les jeux blonde les
cheveux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]